para nuestra audiencia le pido que si
puede ser si puede ser empecemos por una
breve síntesis de los principales
hallazgos de su investigación
gracias buena tarde también para usted
queríamos precisar dos aspectos
fundamentales para hacer una resumen de
lo que se halló por parte del grupo y en
el informe sobre actos que generan una
planeación para un ataque frente a esa
persecución que hemos encontrado y esto
significa también hablar de que esto se
vino realizando a través de reformas
constitucionales legales y de una u otra
manera frente a procesos en donde se
ejecutaron de manera coordinada con
diferentes estructuras del Estado
acciones que fueron sistemáticas y
generalizadas dentro de un ataque que
implica violaciones y crímenes de toda
índole encontramos prueba de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales de tortura de
detenciones arbitrarias de
cierres de espacios cívicos electorales
y sociales que llevan sin lugar a dudas
a concluir al grupo de manera razonable
que hay toda una planeación para ese
ataque con fines de persecución frente a
opositores políticos e inclusive a
personas que se perciben como posibles
opositores este tema culmina con el
periodo de febrero de este año cuando se
genera la expulsión el destierro y la
pérdida de nacionalidad
de varios nicaragüenses
y precisamente Ángela respecto a esta
expulsión cómo debería leerse porque
Estados Unidos por ejemplo la celebró
como una Liberación
creo que de todos modos Hay que entender
que en el momento en que se concede la
posibilidad de que salgan de la
detención ilícita o de la prisión
se genera un doble movimiento por parte
del gobierno nicaragüense que inclusive
tampoco conocían las personas que fueron
llevadas a un avión y es que mientras
ellos estaban firmando un documento en
donde manifestaban la voluntad de irse a
otro país a la par la asamblea estaba
realizando una modificación para generar
la pérdida de la nacionalidad de estas
personas son actos que son casi
inmediatos Ángela muy rápidamente porque
Lamentablemente se nos acaba el tiempo
ustedes piden a la comunidad
internacional que imponga sanciones sin
embargo el gobierno de Ortega y Murillo
está bastante aislado y el aislamiento
no puede propiciar mayores a violaciones
de derechos humanos ante una impunidad
Sí claro y precisamente las sanciones
deben tomarse de manera inmediata
precisamente para generar el principio
de protección en favor de la población
nicaragüense estas acciones son
permitidas por el derecho internacional
y creemos que los países y esa es la
recomendación que hace el Green deben
analizar la posibilidad de imponer estas
sanciones de manera efectiva para lograr
proteger a la población de nicaragüense